para analizar los resultados en el
fútbol europeo este fin de semana
tenemos con nosotros a la directora del
diario as Colombia y de deportes Caracol
radio Sara Castro Sara bienvenida Muchas
gracias por estar acá con nosotros un
gusto como siempre estar con ustedes
Sara comenzamos la segunda mitad de
temporada parece que todavía falta
muchísimo por disputarse en la liga
española particularmente Real Madrid y
Barcelona
qué tan cómodo es este margen para el
líder qué tan manejable puede ser para
el que viene a la casa Sí lo decía bien
ancelotti falta muchísima liga pero yo
creo que hay tres argumentos por los
cuales creo que el Barcelona no diría
que cuatro pero tres principalmente
futbolísticamente sobre lo que ha hecho
Xavi lo primero es un equipo que juega
bien y jugar bien significa imponerse a
través de su idea la segunda es que he
logrado gestionar bien las ventajas es
ser un equipo que una vez iba arriba en
el mercado le costaba leer los momentos
de los partidos y lo que vimos hoy ante
Sevilla es que ha entendido los momentos
y los tiempos para hacer daño a los
rivales y ha logrado sostener no solo
digamos ese ritmo de juego sino también
esta posibilidad de aumentar las
ventajas y sobre todo de sellar los
partidos y la tercera diría yo que es
fundamental y es la concentración y
sobre todo la lealtad a la idea que
tienen estos jugadores después de
dificultades que tuvo Xavi al inicio
en su llegada al Barcelona para poder
implementar lo que él pretendía de este
equipo lo que hemos visto con la
aparición de estos cuatro volantes con
de Jong Hoy no estuvo busquets Pero
entró que sigue muy bien con pedí con
Gaby yo creo que estamos viendo un
equipo que no solo tiene alto
rendimiento futbolístico sino que
también es muy solidario y el cuarto que
era el que se me olvidaba mencionar el
comienzo es que Real Madrid está en esta
curva descendente en la que a la vez
tiene que gestionar esta participación
en Champions no se le viene un partido
bastante difícil con el Liverpool tiene
además Mundial de Clubes es decir tiene
un montón
de torneos para gestionar al tiempo que
ancelotti y Es evidente hoy dejando en
el banco a modric y a Cross que está
buscando un recambio también en el
mediocampo y creo que en esa transición
puede ser que el Real Madrid le cueste
llegarle al Barcelona en esta liga
hablamos también de la Premier League
donde el Manchester City no ha podido
aprovechar la oportunidad de recortar
con respecto al liderato del Arsenal se
dio en la casa del tottenham Gold de
Harry kane y se mantiene a cinco puntos
en la cima con un Manchester United que
atraviesa un momento estelar desde que
las ligas se reanudaron después de la
pausa mundialista Sara se ve factible
una remontada del Manchester obviamente
como decíamos estamos en una etapa muy
temprana de las ligas pero digamos a la
luz de lo que han sido los últimos
resultados se ve factible la verdad es
que nos está gustando mucho este
Manchester United Ha logrado encontrar
un equipo y una manera de muy sólida Me
parece que los rendimientos de Bruno
Fernández lo que está logrando casemiro
y Fred Aunque hoy salió expulsado
casemiro el nivel de Marcos rachford es
impresionante turquesa logrando tener un
equipo bastante competitivo pero está
difícil
que logre llegarle al City y al Arsenal
Arsenal ya hemos hablado de lo que ha
logrado arteta después de incorporar
esta cultura de juego al equipo le costó
al televerton Y esto es natural en una
Premier en la que estábamos
acostumbrados también a unas temporadas
anteriores con puntajes altísimos con
equipos casi perfectos con ese Liverpool
que estuvo en su máximo en su Prime con
este City que tampoco tenía digamos
nunca bajones de rendimiento pero creo
que estamos viendo una Premier mucho más
competitiva y peleada veo difícil que
llegue al Manchester United creería que
la liga va a estar entre Arsenal y el
city Pero bueno faltan 18 fechas faltan
muchos partidos faltan muchos puntos por
disputar diría del City que en este
momento los rendimientos de algunos
jugadores están bajos me sorprende y lo
mencionaremos Ahora más adelante la
salida yo hago cancelo porque también
para el estilo que necesita Guardiola
siempre van a ser fundamentales equipos
que estén muy alineados con la idea y
sobre todo con mucha más experiencia hoy
tottenham lo hizo ver mal lo hizo ver
sin creatividad Pero sabemos que City
tiene grandes jugadores y sobre todo un
entrenador que se abre sabe sobreponerse
a este tipo de situaciones y esta semana
cerró el mercado de fichajes de invierno
con algunos pases Estelares por ejemplo
por citar un caso del de Enzo Fernández
al Chelsea de estos movimientos hay
algunos que podremos ver en lo inmediato
Porque por ejemplo el el traspaso de
Enzo Fernández parece más como una
apuesta a futuro pero en lo inmediato va
a haber fichajes que que van a dar
resultado que van a hacer diferencia lo
denso Fernández sin duda una de las
figuras del mundial es es muy importante
para la Premier muy importante para el
fútbol argentino creo que logró
consolidarse de una manera impresionante
fue presentado ese día y Ya jugó su
primer partido como titular en el
Chelsea y estoy de acuerdo Yo creo que
es una apuesta más a futuro a seguir
digamos trabajando en esta idea que
pretende el Chelsea y y no vi muchos
movimientos significativos Ahora hay que
hablar de jorginho llegando al Arsenal
porque creo que en esto que habíamos
mencionado de arteta intentando
unificar esta idea sobre la que ha
trabajado y cómo ha tenido jugando este
equipo va a ser fundamental Este es un
cinco muy importante juega con Italia lo
hemos visto son cinco de muchísima
calidad no solo es un volante central
posicional sino que es un jugador que
tiene salida y que seguramente le va a
aportar mucho la idea al Arsenal y luego
diría que la llegada de Joao cancelo al
Bayern Múnich es una de las grandes
digamos transferencias no esperadas de
esta temporada y ya estamos viendo que
en dos partidos ha logrado dos
asistencias es un jugador un lateral
derecho muy influyente y le va a aportar
mucho al Bayern en esta Champions League
sin duda